in this video I'm going to talk a little
bit about something quite personal for
me it has to do with my my own
background but I'm doing it in response
to a student of mine who has a friend
who is struggling with with some of
these kinds of issues as a lot of people
are I struggled with them myself so I'm
gonna talk about about adoption what it
means to be adopted and what it was like
for for me still is like for me and
about how you know one how one deals
with it so the question that after you
know talking about it face to face
she emailed me and asked me on behalf of
her friend what I had to do emotionally
mentally or physically to allow myself
to be at peace with my adoption because
many people who are adopted end up
having some sort of some sort of grief
or problems or I don't know how you want
to put it it affects your life I'll just
say I like that and not all the ways in
which it affects your life are
necessarily positive right off the bat
they can't actually be turning into
things that are positive later on you
know for example some of the things that
I've gone through myself and worked
through or you know they worked
themselves out they were no fun at the
time but it makes me able you know now
that I've got a lot more perspective on
it too to have something to say to
somebody who maybe is right in the
middle of those those sort of things or
similar things or at least analogous
things so I guess the best thing for me
to do because I'm not gonna try to you
know talk about you know everybody's
adoption or how it works for for every
single child is to start out talking
about my own case and then I actually
lucked out
I would say compare it to quite a few
people who I know who are also adopted
in that I'm very happy with the family
that I ended up with so you know how did
I end up being adopted well you know of
course there was an unplanned pregnancy
and I'll tell you a little bit about
that but I'm not gonna go into great
detail about that in part because I just
want to respect my my birth mother's
privacy in certain respects and then you
know I was delivered and then I was I
was adopted through Catholic social
services to Anton Sadler and Monique
Sadler my my adoptive parents who I
think of you know when I think of my
parents because I grew up with them and
because of the experience that I had
with them I don't think of them as my
adoptive parents I just think of them as
parents per se you know there's no
qualifier on it and I think of my family
as my my adoptive family as my my family
so anyway my own case my birth mother
was put in a you know fairly common
situation so this would be about 1969
college student ends up being involved
in something non-consensual and ends up
pregnant as a result and there really
wasn't much there to provide her with
with support or help or a direction you
know things really didn't look that well
and she did something a I'm gonna
mention she did something that for me is
very striking instead of you know taking
a lot of different easy way out that
there were she actually worked in the
hospital where I was delivered she she
stayed there and she worked paid to pay
for her room and board and to pay for my
delivery and she made sure that I was
going to be adopted through through
Catholic Catholic social services which
you know was pretty good agency I mean
they took about a year and a half to two
years
something like that for vetting my my
adoptive parents before even like
considering whether to allow them to be
adopted so you know that was that there
was a good agency she did a lot of good
hard work to make sure that I was going
to be somewhere where I would be taken
care of where I would have two parents
and where in a set or in essence I would
have you know better outcomes better
things put at my disposal and I'm really
happy that she did it so my my family
that I was adopted into the Sadler
family you know any family really got to
look at two sides of it there's the
father's family and the mother's family
my father's family wasn't actually the
sadler it was originally scuffed up my
grandfather changed his name because he
was going into business and at the time
that he was there was a lot of prejudice
against against Slavic people so he
changed his name from scuff cut to an
anglicized sadler and he ended up being
a pretty successful guy you know kind of
troubled in a lot of ways that's a whole
different set of stories and my father
grew up in Arlington Heights in a suburb
of Chicago didn't do great in high
school played football got injured you
know you know problem with his knee the
rest of his life
yeah which actually kept him out of
Vietnam not at first but after a while
after my my grandmother like you know
pointed out to the draft board I'm like
the third fourth time that this guy's
walking with a cane so if you sent him
over there he is it go under and he went
on to get his BA he was a student at the
University of wisconsin-madison when he
like my mom and then he went on to law
school and here into CPA he became a tax
attorney so at the time that they
adopted me he was actually in law school
and I think he was also working for the
state if I remember right at that time
my my adoptive mother
Monique Sadler Monique LEM Rees well she
was seeing there when they adopted me
but the memories originally she grew up
in in Chicago in the city and you know
french-canadian family there used to be
like a little french-canadian area where
the French Canadian and Menominee
Indians lived to Chicago at that time
it's just a patchwork of ethnic
districts and in any case they they
lived there they were I guess who
described them as just working class or
lower middle class at that time very
tight-knit close family a lot of people
living on the same block all related to
each other they spent more time with
their cousins either in school or out in
a piece of land in Indiana that all the
uncles got together in a boy they spend
more time with their cousins and they
did with most other people so their
cousins were their friends and within
that family I'll talk about that a
little bit more but within that family
sort of a rule of thumb for figuring out
how you are connected with other people
is for us first cousins are as close as
many people's brothers and sisters are
to them and third cousins for us are as
close as first cousins are for many
other people that's my mom's side of the
family
my dance out of the family not not quite
so much my my grandmother had some
sisters and we would you know see them
and their husbands every once in a while
and they would come visit but but you
know my my grandfather most the time
that I knew him he was retired my
grandmother died when I was pretty young
and so that son of the family have less
and less less impact over over time my
mother's side of the family you know
I've got this massive network of
relations of going all the way back to
my great grandfather and
great-grandmother Pepe and minmei
memories and they had a lot of kids and
some of those kids had a lot of kids
themselves that would be my mom's
generation and then those kids quite a
few of them he had you know quite a few
kids themselves so when we go to a
family reunion if it's a big year there
could be 200 people there because we you
know we're like the Borg you know we
assimilate all this other these other
people who marry into the family or who
are adopted actually into the family in
in my case and in the case of some of my
cousins you become part of this very
close-knit and you know pretty good
affectionate group so I'm pretty happy
with with who I ended up with I have a
sister and she has also adopted from a
different family she's a bit younger
than me a couple years younger than me
and
I've got you know quite a few cousins
first cousins who I'm pretty close with
and then you know a lot of other second
cousins and that's all on my on my mom's
side now things were always so so good
for me I can tell you this
I was never treated by my family whether
my father's family and where my mother's
family as if being adopted meant that I
was in some way less related to them or
less connected with them I was I was
never loved less for being adopted and I
know that's different from the
experience that some of the people that
I've talked with have had so I'm very
thankful for that but I'm also very
cognizant of how vulnerable you know the
adopted child is to that sort of thing
sometimes people can even like read it
in their when it's not actually there
just because you know in families we
often have trouble expressing our
emotions how we truly feel and we get
into you know conflicts or we get into
situations where we don't express
ourselves as well as we'd like to and
then we do you know kind of feel like if
the Tigger heals in or say something
else to fix things and usually it's sort
of like you know you try to fix things
and you end up you know knocking more
things over in the process so I
understand how how that works in my case
I was never made to feel as if I was if
I had less right to be there or I was
less lobbed or anything like that and so
I'm very thankful for that but I did you
know my you know I had questions I knew
from from as early on as I can remember
that I was adopted my mom and dad didn't
conceal that from me
in part because in the previous
generation there had been a lot of
problems with kids you know not being
told and then finding out much later on
and then having all sorts of
psychological
sometimes killing themselves over it so
from my generation we're talking about
you know Gen Xers as far as I know that
the rule of thumb was you tell the kids
were early on and so I was I was told
that my sister was was told to and we
knew that we were adopted and we knew an
adoption consisted in and there would be
this kind of yearning every once in a
while to know something more about where
where I came from where who might my my
birth parents were and fortunately
enough Catholic Social Services had
provided us with Kenneth they're all
short write-ups with no no information
that would actually give away the
identities of who they were but I I knew
for instance that my I knew the
nationalities you know the ethnic
backgrounds of my birth parents
I knew that my birth father was
interested in fencing reading and karate
I don't really remember too much else
from that because I remember being
struck at the time that I read it I had
already gotten into what passed in our
neighborhood for fencing you know kind
of very much into the three musketeer
ISM and Zorro and stuff like that so
even weed well and also other you know
other things sword related so we did
that sort of thing and I was a big
reader so maybe some of that's genetic I
don't know but I also grew up in a
household where people read my dad had a
whole library my mother read to us since
we were kids and I started reading when
I was about three years old in part
because she spent so much time you know
with me you know I'd look at a bookshelf
and I would have all these books like
you know what to do with you know how
did how to give your child an
exceptional mind how to shoot
essentially home schooling me before I
got a school before it was called
homeschooling so coming back to this I
had some periods of my life where I
really wanted to know more about these
these people and for me I think it had
to do
with wanting to know who my birth father
was and there were two main reasons for
that one is I'm a guy right so I think I
thought of it more in terms of wanting
to know the parent who would be more
like me so I would know what to expect
or model myself after or things like
that and remember at that time I had no
idea that it was really my if my birth
mom would put me up for adoption and
that that was a good thing and that you
know my birth father was completely out
of the picture at the time that she did
that through his own choice the other
thing in my case in my sort of
idiosyncratic history was my adoptive
father died when I was 11 so that left a
big big hole in the family and you know
in my teenage years I had kind of uh
want to to define who my birth father
was in part because you know I wanted a
dad and my my birth mom dated and there
was one guy who she dated who I ended up
performing a pretty good relationship
with but most of the guys were kind of
tena Schmucks quite frankly and you know
some of them wanted to be my dad but I
didn't want them to be my dad by any
means and of course when you when you're
when you're thinking about these sort of
things adopted kids go through this
there's there's like this this fantasy
that well my adopt might my real parents
might be somebody who's famous or
somebody who's you know great or you
know I'd connect up with better and it
makes perfect sense because when you're
an adolescent you're alienated and the
whole world is crap anyway and you don't
you know just sort of like figuring out
your your your bearings and everything
so you know you transpose all that stuff
into well if I just met this person that
would be so gonna be so cool so great
and everything would fall in place and
most likely that wouldn't be
at all but it's something that you go
through and there is indeed and I have
been what you could call by temperament
melancholic my entire life and that may
indeed have something to do with with
being adopted because there is there is
something about it no matter how loving
your birth parents are there's something
that's different something that you have
to work your way through something that
is you know like like a grief that you
don't know how to articulate or even
make sense out of and it's very tough to
in part because you know especially if
you're if your adopted family is a good
family you look at them when you look at
how good you've got it you're like man I
shouldn't feel this bad I shouldn't you
know I should be really happy with what
I've got and then you know especially if
you look at what some other adopted kids
have to you'd be like their home is crap
but my home is great so why do I feel
this way well you feel that way and you
feel that way because there is a a part
of you that is grieving that has lost an
attachment to your birth parents
that's it doesn't have to run the show
it doesn't have to dominate everything
but it is something there that has to be
acknowledged so how did I so that's
that's you know with a lot of
aggressions my story I suppose I should
one more part of the story to so my
adoptive mother died when I was 29 she
drowned right after the the turning of
the millennium in a rafting accident in
Costa Rica not too long after that I got
an email from the woman who actually
turned out to be my birth mother and she
managed to track me down with her pretty
ingenious way she sent her mother to so
my grandmother to
the Hall of Records to do some database
indexing and she knew who the deliverer
and she didn't know what my name was but
she knew who the delivering doctor was
and she knew what time I was delivered
because she was there right so they
looked up birth certificates and turned
out there was only one person who was
delivered by that doctor at that time
thankfully there weren't any clerical
errors and then they had a name Gregory
B's Gregory Brian Sadler and they could
go on that so they looked it up and
there actually were more than one
Gregory Brian Sadler's - believe it or
not so she wrote me and at first I was a
little bit skeptical as I think a lot of
people would be and we started
interacting and and you know we
developed a relationship and now you
know I know my two half-brothers and I
know her her husband my my essentially
stepfather and we we see each other
about twice a year so when we get back
to the Midwest and my kids know her as
well as their third grandmother then
I've learned more and more bits of the
story as time is going on but you know
it was I was thirty by the time that
that came about and it wasn't it wasn't
I'd quit looking for a long time I had
been sort of stymied at the time that I
did want to look as Catholic Social
Services was totally unhelpful for me I
had to go back track so I was going into
the army I was eighteen years old and I
wanted to know who my birth father was
and of course they wouldn't give me an
information and they they gave me some
line but you got to be 21 and so I think
when I came out at 21 I didn't come out
of the army that's when I'm saying when
I when I got to to asking them about it
then there is some other glitch like you
know both both parties want had to
reveal the information
something like that any case she tracked
me down and and that it was you know now
I know a part of the picture yeah and I
have never decided to track down my
birth father but my my wife has pointed
out to me that I probably ought to just
because of medical and health
information that probably be a smart
idea
so now on to there's this big question
what did I what what what did I have to
do emotionally or mentally to allow
myself to be at peace with my adoption
but again I think it's easier for me
that it has been for for a lot of people
in part because of the the family that I
was adopted into the resources that they
put at my disposal and how happy I am to
be in that family I would say the first
thing to do is to consider the
alternatives so just imagine and you
have to exercise your imagination a bit
with this but you know construct for
yourself what you're likely birth
parents would have been like and you
know be real honest about it say to
yourself probably they wouldn't stayed
together for one thing a lot of times
it's it's you know single women on their
own we're putting their children up for
adoption and you know that that single
woman could have actually have just
gotten an abortion and said hey it's not
my problem
maybe she was actually pressured to but
chose not to what would it have been
like growing up with with somebody who
you know wasn't ready for for having you
and who probably was going through a lot
of tough things of their own you know
something that that I thought about
today as I was decided what I was gonna
say with this is I'm I'm you know forty
two years old now so I am more than
twice the age I'm actually teaching
college students who are the age I'm
teaching college students older than my
birth mom was at the time that she gave
me away you know when I was teaching
college freshmen that would be the age
that she was and and I look at these
these kids that I teach these young men
and young women and you know I have I
have a pretty good time teaching them
and I don't really have much trouble
relating to them but they are so
incredibly young and it's hard even to
convey that just just how how much you
learn over the course of your life just
you know not just knowledge but you
might call it practical wisdom you know
the modicum of it that we develop you
know the ability to like get by and
figure out how to how to run your life
and how to assess situations and stuff
like that I look back when I was
nineteen eighteen boy I could not have
had a kid that would that would have
really screwed things up for me and I
would have screwed that kid's life up so
badly because you know I mean I I still
don't have it all together I still have
some some problems that I have to work
my way through and I'm slowly making
progress on I look at where I was 20
years ago 20 you know 23 years ago I
would have been a terrible father and I
think if you if you think about it that
way you know if you're say a college
student right now imagine to yourself
and you know really think this through
don't just like imagine to yourself
you know sort of thought bubble oh this
is gonna be such a wonderful thing now
really think it through exercise your
imagination imagine changing diapers all
the time and you know everything being a
mess all the time being tired all the
time you can't do anything with your
friends anymore and you're responsible
for this little thing that seems like
it's always you know like on the verge
you're killing itself I had kids I know
what it's like you know I mean kids are
a handful and imagine that you're you're
on your own too that you're worried
about money you're worried about your
health you're worried about what people
are thinking about you know how while
you're taking care of this kid you're
worried about whether child social
services is ever gonna get called on you
you're worried about all these things
where's the next the meals gonna come
from that'd be really tough wouldn't it
yeah it becomes easier to understand the
decision then to give up a child for
adoption which is not and here's the
other thing too to think about with with
respect to that I think there are some
some birth parents who it's just a
relief thank God somebody take this this
this you know kid off my hands but
there's two other things that are that
are missing in that equation I think for
most birth parents one is that they're
giving that kid up so that kid can have
a better life they're they're behaving
and I understand it's very hard to see
this or feel this for some people but
they're behaving in a loving way by
doing that that may be the most loving
act possible for them to say I know that
if I give this child off my son or my
daughter to this agency that has a great
track record they will place it with
somebody who will
this kid and create opportunities for it
and help them with the things that I
can't help them with and you know keep
them on on a good track so they can
develop and and not wind up you know
where or I am currently or in some other
worse place it's not a hundred percent
guaranteed but it's but it's probable
the things that sort out like that so
that's so that's an act of love it's not
just you know for many birth parents
it's not just a Wow get this kid off my
hands it's a I want this kid doing a
better life the other thing that goes
along with that is is birth parents
grieve birth mothers especially I mean
if the birth father's out of the picture
and he's just kind of a jerk then yeah
it's not an issue right but even some of
them changed their mind later on but
birth you know birth mothers especially
that's tough to actually say I you know
this is my baby
my birth mother only got to hold me once
before she had to to give me away
imagine that she worked in a hospital to
pay for my delivery all the way up to
the point of that delivery and then
she's only allowed to hold me once
makes me sad actually to think about
that you know sad not not for myself but
for her that must've been extremely
tough to not you know say I've changed
my mind to go through that that grieving
process you know so I think that's stuff
to keep in mind when you're considering
the alternatives I would say another
thing that you can do is you know look
very realistically at your adoptive
family odds are if they're like other
human beings they're not perfect and
they're probably you know deeply flawed
in some you know significant ways but
they're probably held a lot better of an
eye
come for you then your birth parents
were at that time you know not every
single case but I'm just talking about
the majority of cases you know actually
look at who your birth parents are what
they're what they're like see how
they've loved you over time how they put
up with your BS I mean if you've been a
teenager you've been a pain in the ass
to somebody guaranteed there's very very
few kids who are not a major pain
disrespectful you know thoughtless
because that's part of the process of
adolescence you know not saying it's a
you know it's not a bad thing but that's
that's the way kids are so I mean look
at them and see how they they actually
dealt with you you know see how they
treated you as their own son or daughter
realize that they actually chose you and
that they even though they didn't have
to they took care of you they attended
to your needs they probably changed your
diapers they you know cleaned you up
when you fell down and got all messed up
they comforted you when some kids were
bugging you at school probably they
taught you some valuable lessons about
how to deal with those kids and how to
deal with other circumstances you know
and if they didn't do a perfect job well
you know nobody does and it's really
easy for adopted kids to say man if I
just been with my birth parents
everything would have been like it's so
much better but if you if you look at it
the odds are no that's that's not the
case at all this group of people that
you actually did grow up with and who
took care of you and who stuck with you
they're your family and they have
behaved towards you the way family is
ought to and families aren't perfect and
families are going to screw things up
you know a lot of I told my ethics
classes this all the time a lot of
ethics is not you know doing the right
thing all the time you know the right
way it's realizing that wow you are
going to screw things up and after
you've screwed things up now it's time
to figure out how now
screw it up even worse and how to get
things somewhat back on track and start
working on it bit by bit by bit and
that's probably what your birth parents
did if they're you know like like most
of the people I've run into I think that
another thing that's really helpful
I found this helpful but I'm hoping that
this video is kind of part of this this
process for you is knowing that other
people are in the same condition if
you're adopted sometimes you feel like
you're the only adopted kid out there
because probably most your friends
aren't and you know if you're a
different ethnicity say then then you're
the rest of your family then it really
sticks out right but even if you're if
you're the same or similar you know it's
the same I mean like my family for
instance pretty quickly you could figure
out I mean definitely were white
Caucasian right but there's lots of
different ways of being that way and
most of my family are little short
people and I was this tall I was I'm 6
foot 3 I was this tall when I was 12 so
I didn't really look like I fit in that
much you know they knowing that other
people are also in the same situation
that you're not alone that there's you
know literally millions of kids out
there not just in your generation but in
previous generations and in current
generations you know coming up dad have
been adopted and that you have something
in common with that helps in my case I
think it was really helpful that I had a
sister who was adopted as well and
adopted from a different family because
that gave us you know already like that
little community of kids who were
adopted but communicating connecting
sharing stories sometimes even if you
don't know why you're doing it I think
that can make you feel a bit better
and over time that can help to give a
bit of perspective to you the one other
thing I'd like to say too is there's
there's a book that I found particularly
helpful there's a lot of literature
about there out there about adoption
hopefully you can see this this is
called being adopted the lifelong search
for self and what I really like about
this book is it goes through all these
different stages of your life and they
say well you know here's what you can
expect to feel like you know to go
through and it tells it from like the
kids perspective and the parents
perspective it's done by some
psychologists and they they give you
some sort of theoretical basis what you
might or might not want but they give
you some idea of why is the kid going
through this sort of stuff why are they
acting this way why do they feel this
way
why aren't they happy with this you know
what are they looking for I found this
book really really helpful and I would
suggest actually getting it getting your
hands on a copy it's pretty pretty easy
to find and I would also suggest that if
you're adopted you know later on you get
serious with somebody and you're
thinking about you know long-term
relationship have them may actually read
this book because it's not just about
kids and parents it's also about you
know spouses and partners and and how -
what to expect you know what to look out
for the last thing that I would say and
this might not work for everybody is
there's really nothing you can do about
being adopted so you're better off if
you just make it part of who you are and
learn how to work your way through it
and be okay with it and I know that
sounds a lot easier than it is you know
and for me you know 42 years and it's
very different than somebody who's you
know 12 or 17 or 21
or 35 or something like that so I don't
mean to trivialize that but you do have
to figure out some way to to come to
terms with that because that fact of
being adopted is not going to change
even if you find your birth parents you
know I have some great reunion and
connect up with them you still were
adopted and you're never going to be
able to change that what you can change
is how you how you understand it how you
feel about it what it means for you and
I think by looking at how other people
have dealt with that that can be very
helpful so hopefully this will be some
some use to you and maybe some use to
some other other people out there who
are struggling with these issues too